will be free president thinks he can
come to Atlanta and not be protested for
the crimes against humanity that he has
committed he is dead wrong sh shame
Jo nothing sacred to these people this
protest went down outside Roslin
Carter's funeral today and now at a time
when I think we need a politics free
Christmas more than ever they're gearing
up to disrupt tomorrow's Rockefeller
Center tree lighting that's going to win
them a lot of friends and last night
they took over a city council meeting in
Denver why because they didn't want the
Jewish National Fund to hold a
conference in the city when activists
compared Denver's hosting the group to
hosting a fundraiser for Nazi Germany
okay that doesn't make any sense
meanwhile the political Fallout for
Biden on this issue among young people
continues citing both the bad economy
and Biden's foreign policy voters ages
18 to 34 are turned off by what the
White House has done and the far left
which turned out big for Biden in 2020
has done a full-on Embrace in some cases
of Hamas and the White House was caught
off guard by comments like this if Hamas
is a terrorist organization then IDF is
a terrorist organization IDF is a bigger
terrorist organization if you ask me you
believe the Israeli retaliation to the
Hamas attack is a
what would you say to those who say
Hamas provoked this that's absolutely
LIE there's no evidence that Hamas
attack Israel killed their own people
absolutely my next guest went viral for
his own speech calling Israel's response
a genocidal attack on Gaza joining me
now Dr Cornell West 2024 Independent
presidential candidate Dr West great to
see you as always now um You and I
disagree I know on a lot of issues but I
think we can have a pretty constructive
conversation here so let's start with
just the basics do you think atrocities
were committed against innocent
civilians by Hamas terrorists on October
7th oh absolutely anytime you kill
innocent people my dear sister that's a
war crime there's no doubt about that
it's in the context of 75 years of a
very vicious Israeli domination and and
occupation but anytime you kill innocent
people it's wrong it's and and when you
kill civilians it those are war crimes
no matter who does it but that's true
whether US Army does it whether Hamas
does it whether the IDF do it whether
the Russian army does it we have to have
some moral consistency here right so at
that point when those crimes occurred
what should Israel have
done well I me I can't I can't run this
I think Israel should have ended the
occupation a long time ago and treat
Palestinians with dignity just stay on
that question though if you don't
mindess okay well let's stay on the
question though these crimes which you
conceded occurred what might have
happened before I understand your views
on that but then what like if someone
came into your house and did that to
your family you would want them to be
you know obviously Justice to be done in
this case Hamas hides among the civilian
population we know that that's one of
their tactics so what should Israel have
done in this case
well I again I think it's a matter of
trying to get at the root of it there
must be responsibility and
accountability for war crimes there's no
doubt about that that's true for the
Palestinians who've been killed every
day for over 75 years that's true for
israelies who were killed in October the
7th there has to be some accountability
and responsibility but you can't jump
into this my dear sister without
understanding the larger context and
backdrop because if we don't get to the
root of this vicious Israeli occupation
we're going to have these cycles of
hatred and violence going on and on and
on that's the real challenge how do you
move in such a way that you can accent
the best in both folk the Palestinians
and Israelis and how do you do that
you've got the end the occupation it's
like Nat Turner when he when he when he
had to the resistance against slavery
right did he killed some innocent white
folk he was wrong but slavery had to go
or you were going to have cycle with
that over and over again that's why
these brothers and sisters here who are
putting their lives on the line there's
something that's POS about that they see
a genocide taking place we got to do
something about it okay so you're it
almost sounds I know you wouldn't do
that but it almost sounds like you're
saying you can explain what they did on
October 7th because you believe that
Israel is occupying their territory and
they had no other option is that what
you're saying
well when JFK said my dear sister that
those who make nonviolent Revolution
impossible make violent revolution
inevitable that's JFK who says that and
and you could imagine any other
politician saying that is true yeah he
wouldn't have been in any place in any
place the Irish the do across the board
anytime you have people under occupation
and and and and and gazel likee
conditions you over time it's going to
over in an ugly way now you know that
just from history right I think it's I
think it's you know history well I by
the by the by by that um way of looking
at things America should just dissolve
today we shouldn't even be a country
because Conquest is part of human
history well conqu Conquest is part of
human history whether it's the in you
know the American Indians were here
first they OCC you know they occupied
the land first America you know so that
conversation is circular and it ends up
there are no countries in most of the
world because at some point other people
were living in those countries but I
want to shift gear because we're not
we're not going to be able to solve this
problem now but I want to shift gears to
go to the presidential race let's go to
the presidential race because I know you
want to talk about that too the regime
media I call them Dr West seems to be
getting scared of you and other third
party candidates that that you're posing
a threat to uh President Biden's
re-election um MSNBC on Sunday folks
there said this let's face it folks
there are Americans out there who don't
want to vote for republicans and they
don't want to vote for Democrats and I
don't doubt the people's preferences but
the chance of a third party candidate
actually winning the presidency in real
life it remains highly unlikely please
tell me again how your vote doesn't
matter folks it does your vote is your
voice um your response Dr
West I think they have good reason to be
afraid because any anybody who wants to
speak the truth when you have a regime
in the in power that denies the truth
anybodys justice who who runs away from
Justice they ought to be afraid but
that's for the Republican party and
that's for the Democratic party both of
them shot through with corruption shot
through with mendacity th shot through
with too many lies and I'm just trying
to stand for truth and Justice my dear
sister as a fallible finite human being
that's what I'm standing for and that's
what I'm going to live and die for well
Dr West thank you for joining us we
really appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else